if you watch the news during a
presidential election you'll hear a lot
of this
what do the national polls look like
hillary clinton's national league
nationally joe biden is currently ahead
but these national polls
don't actually tell you who's going to
win throw the national polls out the
window they
don't matter at all what matters are
those swing states
ah yes the swing states most democracies
around the world
elect their head of state with a popular
vote so whoever gets the most votes wins
but in america we do it a little
differently
the us is the only country that picks
its president using something called the
electoral college
it's made up of delegates from each u.s
state when americans vote for president
what they're
actually voting for is who their state
will vote for
this is why every so often someone wins
the presidency without winning the
popular vote
that's happened twice in just the past
20 years
the majority of americans do not like
the system and
haven't for a long time both political
parties have made attempts to get rid of
it
so why does the u.s still use the
electoral college
and who actually benefits from it
the electoral college is based on how
people are represented in congress
where each state has a number of
representatives based on its population
and every state also gets two senators
so for example let's look at texas which
has a huge population
and vermont which has a really small one
texas has 36 representatives in congress
vermont only gets one representatives in
both states each represent roughly the
same number of people
in the electoral college a state gets
the same number of delegates as their
congressional representatives
plus two for each senator so texas has
38 electoral votes
vermont has three but this combination
makes the number of people each delegate
represents way different between states
in texas one electoral delegate
represents three times the amount of
people
as one in vermont and that makes each
individual person's vote in vermont
a lot more influential the electoral
college creates discrepancies like this
all over the country a voter in wyoming
is worth three and a half times as much
as a voter in california
and the winner of the presidential
election is the candidate who gets
270 or more of these electoral college
votes
[Music]
these are the results of the 2016
election by state
you're probably more familiar with this
version of it a map of red states and
blue states
but this chart tells a different story
you can see that no state is actually
all red or all blue but almost
every state awards its electoral votes
the same way
the candidate who gets the most votes in
a state gets all its electoral votes
if they win the state by one percent
they win a hundred percent of the
electoral votes
in 2016 more than four million people
voted for donald trump in california
in fact more people voted for him there
than in any other state
except for two but it didn't matter
hillary clinton got more votes there
so she got all 55 of its electoral votes
clinton never even campaigned in
california polling showed she'd easily
win the state
trump only visited texas once he knew
he'd basically had that state's
electoral votes locked
but they both visited florida 35 or more
times
that's because florida is usually a
swing state polls show that the vote
there could swing to one party or
another nearly every election
trump only won it in 2016 by 100 000
votes
out of more than 9 million swing seats
have changed over time thanks to
shifting demographics and political
views
and it's states like these where
presidential candidates spend most of
their time campaigning
it also means these states have way more
influence over the election
than these ones a study found that
voters in michigan had
51 times the amount of influence on the
2016 election
as someone from a state like utah voters
in states like california or missouri
mattered very little swing states are
where the election
actually takes place they get the
attention and the influence
and they only exist because of the
electoral college
it doesn't seem very fair but the
electoral college has
always shifted power away from some
people and towards others
it was how it was designed back when
there were just a few states not
50 they had to get all the states to
agree on the constitution
one problem the northern states which
were largely anti-slavery wanted only
free people to count in the population
towards electoral votes
which they had more of the pro-slavery
southern states were worried that they
would be
constantly outvoted and wanted enslaved
people to count in determining the
population
as a compromise they settled on
something called the three-fist clause
it established that an enslaved person
would only count as
three-fifths of a person in 1800
pennsylvania
northern state and virginia a southern
one had about the same number of free
people living there
but virginia was also home to hundreds
of thousands of enslaved people
who had no freedom let alone a vote and
ended up with
more votes in the electoral college than
pennsylvania
that year those extra electoral votes
gave the candidate from virginia
just enough to win
even after the u.s finally abolished
slavery and eventually gave black
americans the right to vote
white southern leaders found ways to
keep them from voting
like with discriminating laws like poll
taxes and
acts of violence this meant they
continued to have over-representation in
the electoral college
on behalf of a large population that
couldn't vote
the first time congress attempted to
replace the electoral college with a
simple popular vote
was back in 1816 but senators from
southern states blocked it
saying it would be deeply injurious to
them in 1969
congress came even closer replacing the
electoral college had support in both
parties
and even passed the house but it was
blocked again
by southern senators a senator from
alabama wrote the electoral college
is one of the south's few remaining
political safeguards
let's keep it why change a system that
historically had and
still was benefiting white southerners
today the states that the electoral
college benefits have changed
but it's still making some voters more
powerful than others
if we look at the states with a lot of
electoral votes for not a lot of people
and the states with a little electoral
votes for a lot of people
these states are a lot wider and less
diverse than the rest of america
and many of these states are republican
strongholds
these tend to vote democratic that's one
reason the two most
recent republican presidents have won
the electoral college without winning
the popular vote
and since it's currently democrats that
are primarily disadvantaged by the
electoral college
they're the ones leading the charge to
replace it with a popular vote
get rid of the electoral college
but as politics have changed the people
most critical of the electoral college
have
two in the 1948 presidential election
new york ended up being the major swing
state
a congressman from texas said i have no
objection to the negro and harlem voting
but i do resent the fact that his vote
is worth a hundred times as much
as the vote of a white man in texas
swing states change
what doesn't is that the electoral
college gives certain people
more power to pick the president and its
biggest defenders
have always been those who benefit the
most from it
[Music]
thanks to absolute who sponsored this
video to remind all americans to make
the time
to vote absolute doesn't influence our
editorial but they do make videos like
this possible
so drink responsibly and vote
responsibly